showtime
ich frage euch sicherlich bis zu dieser
situation gekommen ist aber erzählen wir
die geschichte lieber von anfang an
halo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
wir sind gerade in einen in der türkei
zur olivenernte
ihr wisst wir waren hier auch schon im
letzten jahr und haben letztes jahr
erstmalig unser olivenöl hergestellt
unser eigenes olivenöl
wer mich hier olivenhaine gepachtet und
haben dann mit einem experten zusammen
mit dem mahmud zusammen unsere olivenöl
hergestellt
ihr wisst auch vielleicht noch ich habe
letztes jahr erzählte olivenöl
herstellung ist wirklich eine
vertrauenssache man kann das ganze immer
nie so richtig nachvollziehen schaut
euch auf jeden fall das alte video an
aber auch in diesem video gibt es neue
informationen und es gibt später auch
noch ein paar highlights aber dazu
später was ich auf jeden fall sagen
möchte wir haben aus dem letzten jahr
einiges gelernt dass olivenöl war
wirklich ausgezeichnet wir verwenden
ausschließlich olivenöl der frühe ernte
warum und weshalb erzähle ich euch
später gerne noch einmal zum auffrischen
was wir hier aber auch gelernt haben ist
während ein letztes jahr war auch das
erste mal war ein bisschen weniger
olivenöl deswegen haben wir die sechser
kompakt mal direkt nochmal ein
olivenhain mit dazu dieser liegt jetzt
auch ein bisschen höher hat vorteile hat
aber auch nachteile der große nachteil
ist man kommt mit dem traktor gar nicht
erst hoch deswegen sitze ich hier auch
auf einem pferd gut wir können da jetzt
kurz hoch laufen mit dem pferd aber wir
müssen später die oliven die wir
geerntet haben einfach mit dem esel
natürlich auch nach unten bringen ins
tal damit wird das ganze zur
produktionsstätte bringen können ich
würde sagen wo ratgeber hoch ernten die
oliven ja der hund da ist so süß
ich glaube ich lasse ihn nicht schleppen
ich glaube ich dass
die tiere nicht schleppen also los
geht's nach oben
hast du dich gerade als ziel wird sein
alles nichts kopf alles gute
wo du dich schön aus
sondern würde ich sagen bevor die
mittagssonne kommt gehen wir jetzt
oliven pflücken was wir hier oben haben
ist also wir sind jetzt wirklich noch
mal ein stück weit höher als die alten
olivenhaine und hier oben ist ein ganz
ganz tolles wetter man muss auch erzählt
dieses jahr war es wirklich extrem heiß
teilweise bis zu 51 grad celsius und
deswegen wurden hier auch
wasserleitungen gelegt damit die
olivenbäume einfach nicht unterversorgt
sind man sieht es auch ganz schön an den
oliven gut der baum hier wurden
abgeerntet aber bei denen da vorne sehen
was gleich die oliven sind einfach
richtig schön knackig und saftig und
einfach nicht so ausgetrocknet und wir
werden jetzt hier die oliven wieder
nicht maschinell sondern per hand ernten
und es auch wirklich ein ganz ganz
großes thema denn unsere zuschauer haben
uns schon darauf angesprochen und haben
gefragt ob denn unser olivenöl nicht ob
es legal ist oder eben nicht vegan ist
und wir uns nicht gefragt wo die neu ist
auch vegan also was soll denn daran
nicht vegan sein und ich habe mich dann
aber gelesen und es ist wirklich so dass
bei diesen super intensiven betrieben so
werden nämlich diese großbetriebe
bezeichnet die eben ganz ganz viel
olivenöl ernten da ist es leider so dass
sie wirklich nachts ernten und auch
komplett maschinell das heißt gar keine
erntehelfer und da ist es leider so dass
wirklich ganz oft sinkt für die
betroffenen sind und wirklich weltweit
millionen singvögel jedes jahr ihr leben
lassen bei der olivenernte was er
traurig ist weil ich finde das ganz ohne
arbeit in die ernte des olivenöls was
wirklich sehr ökologisch machbar ist
nachhaltig machbar ist und vor allem
auch tierlieb und so machen wir das und
so machen es auch viele andere
familienbetriebe und traditionelle
betriebe sie ernten neben noch mit
menschen und eben halb maschinell dass
wir diese rüttelmaschine dass wir die
oliven vom baum bekommen aber alles
andere wird per hand geerntet da kommt
kein tier schaden zu stande und vor
allem hier oben bei uns ist es auch so
dass wir gar keine pestizide benötigen
keine schädlingsbekämpfungsmittel weil
wir so weit oben sind dass hier die
fruchtfliege diese oliven pflege gar
nicht erst ansiedelt und wir somit keine
schädlingsbekämpfungsmittel verwenden
müssen wird sagen ich gehe es nach vorne
die erntehelfer die treffen ist nämlich
jeden moment ein wir ernten jetzt unsere
oliven und machen unser eigenes erleben
er ist ein talent baum schüttler und
zwar ist es für die erste wo die bäume
sehr sehr hoch sind als sehr groß sind
hat man hier fertig war das schüttelt
genau und es ist für die oberen wipfel
und unten kann man ganz normal mit einer
harke darum gehen aber wie gesagt wo man
hinkommt einfach in die este rein
und unten einfach mit zur lokale kam es
einfach durchkämmen
das heißt wenn man es heißt an den
olivenhain durchkämpft dennoch mit dem
sicher hier
sammer hier die bäume alle ab gerüttelt
und sammeln jetzt die oliven auf und was
wir hier wieder haben wie beim letzten
jahr das ist einfach die oliven frühe
ernte und die hat den vorteil dass ich
einen ganz hohen gehalt an polyphenolen
und antioxidantien habe und das olivenöl
somit sehr gesund ist und sekt
gesundheitsförderliche polyphenole sind
nämlich die freunde unserer blutgefäße
denn sie schützen uns vor oxidieren dem
cholesterin denn nur wenn cholesterin
oxidiert und klebstoffe aktiv sind
setzen die sich als ablagerung an die
gefäßwände und das wollen wir natürlich
nicht und das verhindern genau
polyphenole sie sind nämlich sekundäre
pflanzenstoffe und schützen so unseren
körper
man merkt es auch so ein bisschen wenn
man es probiert dann hat es so einen
scharfen abgang am ende man muss auch
davon husten ganz oft aber das ist
völlig normal und im essen später
schmeckt man es auch gar nicht es
wirklich immer noch so cool probiert
dann erkennt man dass reine gute
olivenöl aus der frühe ernte und das
machen echt nicht viele nehmen nur 0 5
prozent der gesamten welt ernte wird
überhaupt in der frühe ernte gemacht
weil sie ist finanziell einfach nicht
lohnt wie gesagt man bekommt nur ein
drittel von dem was man normalerweise
beim normalen ernte bekommen sollte und
deswegen macht es auch wirklich keiner
und hier sind die ganzen stoffe drin die
wichtigsten für ein gutes olivenöl und
man kennen erkenntnissen gutes olivenöl
auch an der farbe das muss so leicht
grünlich sein das sagt nicht ins ins
klar gelbliche reingehen gelblich heißt
eigentlich dass es wie soll ich sagen
das ist schon fast schon an sich ist
aber zu grün darfst auch nicht sein da
benutzen viele nämlich die blätter was
genau damals gibt es einen trick um
olivenöl so auszusehen lassen das ist
aus der frühe ernte ist kann zwar presst
man einfach die blätter mit und da sind
auch schwebeteilchen darin dass auch ein
bisschen gefährlich wenn im olivenöl
schwebeteilchen drin sind dann wird es
auch schneller ranzig habe ich recht bei
uns jetzt gut gefällt hat genau das
heißt wir hätten jetzt auch zwei drei
monaten noch warten können hätten ganz
viel olivenöl herstellen können dass wir
noch mehr haben aber wir haben jetzt
sagt wir nehmen jetzt wieder die frühe
ernte deswegen sind wir jetzt auch recht
früh da und haben lieber weniger aber
dafür das beste
ja wir sind ja jetzt ziemlich weit oben
auf dem berg jetzt natürlich weder strom
noch von einer anbindung und zur
stärkung haben wir uns hier versammelt
es werden immer so drei vier meist
frauen abkommandiert und die bereiten
dann hier die verpflegung vor heute gibt
es bei uns hier gößling und leckere
pfannengerichte natürlich alles im
freien und alles hier auf feuer gegart
und ich bereite jetzt hier mit den leben
damen das essen zu wir machen den zierte
sind teig und da haben eine füllung der
vegetarische sogar vegane füllung aus
spinat und lauch ein bisschen kräutern
und es kommt jetzt hier alles schön rein
und dann packen wir das hier oben damit
alles schön wieder gepflegt und gestärkt
sind für die meisten
bis zu entschleunigen grad hier daheim
habe ich so gerätschaften kennwort gefu
griff alles schneider da würde ich eins
nach dem anderen durch jagen und hepp wo
innerhalb von 30 minuten acht gänge menü
für 20 und im hintergrund einfach so der
erde
dort
nicht das doch
nicht liebt es hier ich habe mich jetzt
noch kartoffeln übrig von unserem
gelände und die schneide ich jetzt
einfach und macht ob es los marin
olivenöl drauf salz pfeffer
das reicht mehr braucht
jetzt fängt gleich und werde dann die
tiere merken es auch schon war der warte
kurz warte kurzem auch der esel auch
angst weil
das wetter schlechter hat richtig um ich
denke wir gehen jetzt richtung nach
unten
er will die oliven olive aber
normalerweise durch jetzt insel ist
alles in seinem körper rein aber ich
mache das jetzt ragen jetzt selber weil
er so komme ich verschont ich heute
kommt mit dann ist noch richtig vegan
ist ja
komm
komm schatz
wie die bilder fall nicht so schnell
kommen die paar meter schaffen um auch
ohne
goalie
es gibt keine straße
wir froh das lied auf fertig geerntet
haben denn das wetter zieht richtig zu
es gibt gleich ein heftiges gewitter wir
laden jetzt hier den traktor noch auf
und dann geht es direkt zur olivenöl
produktion
ok murat
kommentar zwecke ein bisschen aus dem
weniger
auskommen kaum ein schatz
was ich geschafft habe
aber danke schön vielen dank auch gott
ist nämlich am liebsten mitnehmen wohnen
zwar ein süßer
nächstes jahr wieder okay
ich bin ich weg
jetzt sind wir hier an der
produktionsstätte bei mahmud dschibril
ja und hier wird unser olivenöl
produziert wie im letzten jahr auch
schon und im letzten jahr haben wir euch
schon gezeigt wird das reine olivenöl
hergestellt wird wir haben außerdem noch
ein chili olivenöl hergestellt und in
diesem jahr gibt es zwei neuheiten
denn während so ein bisschen auf die
community gehört und haben herausgehört
dass hier auch gerne weitere geschmack
olivenöle haben möchtet deswegen man
sieht sie auch schon ein bisschen und
ich fühle mich gerade wie im siebten
himmel während murat nämlich die oliven
kisten geschleppt habe ich gedacht
zeigen wir euch jetzt schon mal was wir
noch machen werden und so knoblauch
olivenöl und später zeige ich euch auch
noch rosmarin oliven am liebsten würde
ich einfach hier bleiben denn ich liebe
knobloch und dieser hier ist ganz
besonders und zwar ist der knoblauch
ausraster mono aus der türkischen
provinz tak gipfel der ist nicht nur
geschmacklich hervorragend sondern hat
auch die besten gesundheitlichen
vorteile muss man echt dazu sagen und 90
prozent des knoblauchs auf der erde
kommt wirklich aus china und ein teil
der bei uns in europa landet ist auch
aus spanien man muss aber dazu sagen
dass die mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so
aromatisch sind und deswegen haben wir
hier bewusst auf den regionalen
knoblauch zurückgegriffen der ist
wirklich der hammer man erkennt man auch
daran dass die schale außen weiß ist im
innern leicht lila und die knoblauchzehe
zu trends farben ist der ist einfach vom
geschmack her der beste muss man echt
dazu sagen
nur das beste für unsere live
ich glaube ich bin für unterwegs an der
see noch eine knolle mit
nachdem auf joghurt drauf lecker und
dann stellen wir noch rosmarin olivenöl
her und das machen wir mit hilfe von
bildern rosmarin muss man dazu sagen
nun ist der
hat da ist schnell erzählt
es hat einen termin nennen aber man
sieht ja
also wir werden jetzt die rosmarinnadeln
von holzigen teil entfernt das ist sehr
aufwändig muss ich sagen ich meine ich
benutze auch sehr gerne rosmarin ich
steck dann immer so einen ganzen
rosmarin strauch irgendwo mit rein und
nehmen den später mit raus geht hierbei
der olivenöl produktion natürlich nicht
das heißt die einzelnen adel müssen
jetzt hier wirklich schön sorgsam
entfernt werden dann wird das ganze auch
mit den oliven gemeinsamen vermischt
verkleinert und geknetet weiteres möchte
uns nicht beraten diesen
betriebsgeheimnis aber wie so eine art t
auf post wird hier gemacht in
verschiedenen verfahren so dass später
einfach dieser tolle rosmarin geschmack
im olivenöl mit drin ist und das ganze
aber auch nicht bitter schmeckt ein
hervorragendes linie wird jetzt schon
probiert
und dazu kartoffeln oder steak
das wird der hammer ich glaube ich
dieses auch einfach über kommen ja
ja schon mal was was ist was ist kümmern
mir ist ein bisschen peinlich aber eher
zu letztes jahr haben nämlich ein
folklore kleidung reingesteckt und ich
muss dir tanzen und meine ganze familie
sind alle meine ehemaligen
arbeitskollegen im alle jugendliche
gedacht wenn ich kann die tradition der
mann aber wie ich kann nicht tanzen
versteht was ich meine ich sag bescheid
aus verstehen uns nicht mal ein auch
wenn es auch wenn die kultur zeigen
möchte aber irgendwie so ich verstehe
dass ich meine dann sind wir auf die
rosenfelder in rosenfeld haben mir so
mützen angezogen und zunächst ohne jacke
und ich sah aus wie so ein ständig
weiter bestand welche man geht aus
rosenfeld und großen wie oft versteht
was ich meine ich sah aus wie ein
türkischer rosenverkäufer ok keiner gar
keiner und dieses jahr ich habe gedacht
dass wir besser und diesmal hatte er und
fährt gegeben und mir ein esel erzähle
bitte nicht dass es keine pferde
integriert türkei gibt ja zehn wir dass
wir nicht
eigentlich so groß versteht was ich
meine da muss doch zwei paare geben
warum es kam einfach so es reicht jetzt
bitte ich langsam vernichtet und ich bin
was richtig ist was man isst was mit
muskeln so was mit schwertern irgendwas
und was wo ich sagen kann wo so spart
gladiator mäßig irgendwas möchte ich
haben persönlich meint fink was bitte
macht irgendetwas
ich glaube wir haben schon genau das
richtige für dich organisiert
ich habe da draußen die überraschung für
dich vorbereitet jetzt ja
so richtig so wie er sich traum kurs
richtig mit muskeln bisschen gewalt ok
hirsch ich glaub ich geh doch lieber
transfer
natürlich normalerweise hätte ich jetzt
mit diesen zwei jungs gerungen aber ich
habe dinge letztes mal beim volleyball
habe ich mir tennis auf jeden fall
wollte ich sagen das ist die älteste
sportart der welt nahm tontaubenschießen
ist es das türkische öl ringen die
türkei ist eine regulation und die
türken sind spezialisten für öl ringen
öhringen ist einer der schwersten kampf
sportarten der welt weil diese jungs die
werden wirklich mit öl eingerieben und
du kannst dich eigentlich nirgendwo
halten sie ein bisschen komisch aus ist
aber ein ganz ganz eine ganz ganz krasse
kampfsportler würde ich sagen ja auf
jeden fall jetzt haben wir das olivenöl
dass ich mal ganz kurz
und mit diesem olivenöl werden sich die
jungs mitnichten man ist auch möglich
traditionell einreiben ja wo der himmel
so nicht habe jetzt mal ganz kurz diese
sportler eigentlich ganz ganz easy und
zwar verloren hat der der auf beiden
schultern landet das sind diese typische
rigorosen diesen aus leder aus richtung
gehen und diesen platz und jetzt ist es
so hier ist alles genäht das heißt man
kann nur hier heben man kann ihnen hier
heben dafür brauchen wir richtig viel
kraft in den fingern oder man geht
wirklich in die hose rein ich hoffe ich
erwische nicht gott ich habe mich so wie
es gott sei dank da kannst du hier leben
und darüber werfen genau und die jungs
das sind welche profis sind in der
türkei volkshelden pass mal auf jungs
das ist wirklich krass was die jungs
draufhaben was auf einmal das
wahnsinn oder aus dem stand heraus ich
habe erst beigebracht hat gut von mir
hören indem er hat heute haben ja ich
habe es heute um heißt ich bin sein
lehrer ich habe sie mir zeit und er kann
es auch aus dem lauf wie die japanische
okay jetzt pass mal auf
in der türkei gibt es vier
meisterschaften die sind ganz ganz
wichtig und wird nur zum beispiel hat
schon acht medaillen gewonnen und zwar
acht hier genau das hier noch acht mal
hat er gewonnen und jetzt werden sie uns
den kampf fortführen und bevor so ein
kampf anfängt kommt erst die zeremonie
das ist ganz ganz wichtig und bei der
zeremonie werden alle zuschauer begrüßt
das machen sie jetzt mal
okay
ok jetzt lassen wir uns mal kämpfen
normalerweise ist so dass der rasen noch
feucht gemacht wird weil jetzt ist der
reise möglich messerscharf das tut ihm
auch weh ich hoffe sie übertreiben nicht
dann fang mal okay ready steady go
mich ist in ordnung ist ja es ist ja
versichert
jetzt begrüßen sich das bald ein ritual
und jetzt fangen sie an
jetzt war auf den schultern das war der
finishing move jetzt hat in kürze
schulden gehabt haben das ding verloren
genau wahnsinn also ich deswegen will
ich also ringen ist eine krasse sportart
wenn er selber oder auch box ist
klassisch portal da brauchst du wirklich
eine ausdauer wie so ein marathonläufer
und und dann noch diese masse was die
jungs hier haben ich habe niemals ja
auch aber ich habe aufgehört zu
trainieren ja auf jeden fall
wahnsinnig wirklich ganz ganz krass ich
bin echt stolz auf euch alle
wir gehen dann weiter zur olivenöl
produktion
mir macht bei dem mix perverses bitte
ich bitte dich an meine eltern schauen
zu
so sehen die töpfe jetzt aus schön
bemalt und jetzt werden sie noch
glasiert und nach dem brennofen sehen
sie dann so aus also so sind natürlich
alle noch ein bisschen matsch die farben
sind nicht so stark aber nach dem
brennen kommt die farbe richtig schön
durch und wenn mit ihr wieder das
rainbow die seien dann die einfarbigen
und die streifen designs und so stellen
wir jetzt alle fertig und dann zeige ich
euch
da sind wir jetzt also wie im letzten
jahr gibt es auch in diesem jahr wieder
unsere schöne handgemachte keramik
flasche und ich muss sagen ich bin nach
wie vor verliebt denn wir haben ja auch
hier wieder verschiedene designs rainbow
ist so mein favorit aber auch die
einfarbigen finde ich echt schön und die
gestreiften und gepunkteten die sind
echt toll ja und was wir dieses jahr
eben neu haben eben die geschmacks
olivenöle chili hatten wir schon und
rosmarin und knoblauch kommt jetzt
neuerdings mit dazu die ideen kamen
übrigens auch von den zuschauern also
also ihr brauchte sich denken dass die
super hirn ist sind
sondern ja sonst möglich die ganzen
ideen kamen auf den zuschauern und wir
haben auch aus den fehlern vom letzten
jahr gelernt zum beispiel dieses jahr
ist es wirklich so dass olivenöl war er
nach zwei tagen eine schon ausverkauft
komplett online und haben uns überlegt
dass dieses jahr so ist dass man nicht
mehr zehn flaschen kaufen kann und zwar
ist es eine begrenzung drin maximal pro
haushalt fünf flaschen ganz ganz wichtig
dass da haben wir gelernt und wo wir
auch gelernt er bleibt weil die dhl dann
schneller waren die haben dann so alles
vorweg gegriffen und dann sind wir immer
so im zwiespalt und dann haben wir
gesagt kommt dieses jahr so online eine
begrenzung auf jeden fall und letztes
jahr war das glück in anführungsstrichen
dass wir dann in mannheim im store noch
welche hatten und die dann immer wieder
in den onlineshops schicken weil mit dem
laden laden zu weil der laden zwar wegen
der pandemie und jetzt ist ja auch so
gewesen dass man auch ehrlich sagen muss
dass olivenöl ist nicht ist nicht
günstig also es ist nicht billig
günstiges preis es ist weiß aber
natürlich zahlt man bei der
handgemachten keramik flasche natürlich
auch die ganze handarbeit denn diese
flaschen die werden ja per hand gegossen
dann werden sie geschliffen sie werden
gebrannt per hand angemalt nochmal
glasiert also es sind so viele
arbeitsschritte bis zu dieser fertigen
flasche und dann ist es ja oft sogar
noch so gewesen dass man immer nicht
wusste ist die flasche jetzt perfekt
oder nicht kommt sie gut aus dem ofen
raus also da hat man schon immer sehr
viele verluste und dann das olivenöl
rein für hunt per hand verschließen wir
werden beide selber wie anstrengend das
war mit dem apfel und da konnte man
einfach mal stehen ja nichts machen und
deswegen hat diese flasche natürlich
auch ihren preis aber ihr sollt die
flasche auch gar nicht entsorgen denn
die flasche ist eine richtig schöne
dekorative vase auch die als vase
verwenden könnt oder können sie ja immer
wieder auf flügen und dann war's ja was
man auch noch außerhalb der flasche
sagen muss es ist natürlich die frühe
und die macht auf der welt nur 0,5
prozent der gesamternte aus ganz ganz
wichtig und sie ist nun nur aus einem
garten und noch aus einer sorte das
macht ihn auf der welt auch kaum jemand
das ist auch die besonderheit des öls
und haben uns gedacht manche von euch
haben wir schon viele flaschen geholt
und dann noch mehr flaschen kaufen noch
mehr flaschen damals gedacht irgendwann
ist der haushalt folgen und deswegen
haben wir jetzt diesen kanister ich
meine da ist auch schön aber den würde
ich mir jetzt nicht dekorativ in die
küche stellen das mache ich natürlich
noch mit dem keramik flaschen aber der
ist natürlich viel günstiger als die
keramik flasche weil man den einfach
immer wieder auffüllen kann oder
verwenden kann und daneben den kanister
irgendwann einfach entsorgt aus diesem
fehler auch gelernt da haben uns ja auch
schon ein paar angeschrieben und zwar
was dieser deckel hier dieser deckel
hier hat ja hier noch ein verschluss und
er hat sich mit der zeit gelöst das
heißt dieses jahr sind die decke stärker
viel stärker und ist aber nicht schlimm
das öl ist sehr wichtig und was jetzt
auch bei den kanistern ist immer so ein
deckel mit dabei das heißt wenn ihr eure
flaschen auffüllt ist so ein deckel mit
dabei da können die flasche damit wieder
verschließen da muss man natürlich auto
zu sagen wir mussten ja da auch ein
lebensmittel echten kleber verwenden und
dann wenn man eben ganz wenig benutzt
und dann ist klar dass sich der kleber
irgendwann löst mein gott deswegen legen
wir einfach die flaschen dazu was wir
uns auch überlegt haben dass ihr euren
flaschen schön dekorativ in der küche
aufbewahren könnt haben wir jetzt hier
einfach so ein schönes olivenholz einen
schönen holz untersetzer für zwei
flaschen wir haben auch holz besteck
gemacht aus olivenholz und auch diese
töpfe und bei den töpfen ist es nämlich
so die werden wir für unsere marke
raspberry herstellen und zwar sind es
auch handgemachte keramik köpfe aus der
gleichen töpferei wie eben unsere
keramik flaschen und die werden wirklich
auf einem drehteller alle per hand
hergestellt
ich habe mich auch schon dran versucht
das ist gar nicht so einfach also der
osterhase muster hat gesagt dass man
dafür wirklich ein workshop brauch von
etwa sechs monaten und dann bekommt man
es oft immer noch nicht hin also gerade
dieser handgemachten tonarbeiten ist
wirklich sehr anstrengend und sehr
aufwendig die werden nämlich per hand
gedreht man muss den ton richtig kneten
die technik beherrschen und bei mir ist
einmalig ob entstanden einmal habe ich
eine schale hergestellt muss ich sagen
es wird dann eher sowas wie eine salat
schale und die werden dann getrocknet
werden dann wieder per hand bemalt in
den verschiedenen designs und da haben
wir uns wieder an unseren olivenöl
flaschen orientiert und haben einfach
die designs übernommen von den oliven
flaschen das heißt einmal die schöne
farbe mit rainbow dann auch hier dieses
schöne grau auch die einfachen und
einfarbigen designs und die werden dann
alle getrocknet lanciert und gebrannt
und am ende hat man dann eben so einen
schönen übertopf und kann da zum
beispiel ein schönes kleines
olivenbäumchen einpflanzen und die töpfe
die kann man in und outdoor verwenden
unten haben sie eine öffnung also ein
loch zum abfließen des wassers und da
gibt es aber noch ein stöpsel mit dabei
der stöpsel ist sozusagen da wenn man
das ganze drin verwendet damit das
wasser nicht ausläuft auf euren fußboden
oder auf eure fensterbank und draußen
kann man den stöpsel entfernen und dann
kann das wasser und regenwasser einfach
schön abfließen und ich habe zum
beispiel unseren olivenbaum eingepflanzt
und eine schöne drainage reihen das
heißt ein bisschen steine kieselsteine
dann erde aufgefüllt und dann den
olivenbaum eingepflanzt genau und im
winter könnte den olivenbaum einfach ins
haus rein stellen mache den stöpsel
wieder rein und dann einfach und wo viel
licht ist wenn eine garage hat mit licht
oder im hausgang geht auch und einfach
drin stehen lassen und im frühjahr
wieder raus stellen wenn die temperatur
wird in die plusgrade gehen aber am
besten bei maximal fünf bis zehn grad
also wirklich einen hausflur oder eine
garage im keller mit bisschen licht denn
auch bei zu viel wärme geht der uniform
im innern natürlich kaputt genau und so
könnt ihr wirklich dann gibt es daher
diese diesen blumentopf und ist ein topf
mit der pflanze wird von uns so
verschickt
ja das war das nächste highlight und auf
was ich mich ganz besonders freue das
ist unser schönes vierer geschenkset und
zwar ins hier gedacht wir haben ja diese
großen keramik flaschen auch mit dem
geschmacks öl aber vielleicht traut sich
nicht jeder dran direkten halben liter
knoblauch öl oder rosmarinöl zu
probieren und deswegen haben wir uns
gedacht machen wir das ganze als vier
kleine flaschen zur zum probieren zum
verschenken und die sind echt süß muss
ich sagen vor allem sind sie praktisch
man kann sie auch schnell mal
aufbrauchen und hat eigentlich immer ein
schönes mit
jetzt ist das olivenöl fertig aber bevor
es abgefüllt wird muss es natürlich erst
mal getestet werden wer mit der
hauseigenen laboren und da bewerten wir
dann den geschmack und kontrollieren
natürlich auch die qualität des
olivenöls das machen nicht nur wie hier
hausintern sondern es kommen auch
staatliche ganz unabhängige labore die
das olivenöl testen damit überhaupt erst
auf den markt kommen kann das ist auch
ganz wichtig der testet man eben auch
den verfall am ablaufdatum der testet
man den geschmack eben auch wobei der
recht relativ ist und aber ganz wichtig
eben die qualität des originals und wir
testen dann auch noch das olivenöl in
laboren wenn es nach deutschland kommt
so sind wir einfach auf der sicheren
seite das heißt ich in dem es ihr
einfach mal eine probe und
dann gehe ich jetzt damit zum professor
ins labor
aber eines kann ich schon sagen
geruchsprobe ist perfekt
das olivenöl hat jetzt etliche
testverfahren durchlaufen alle tests
sind sehr gut und ausgezeichnet das
heißt für uns unser olivenöl kann
endlich abgefüllt und abgepackt werden
und jetzt sind wir hier wieder in der
abfüllanlage und auch beim fast
aufwendigsten part muss ich sagen da
schnell schnell schnell gehen wir
schnell was still
ja schon überfüllt ja ja
achja
monats fertig stunde und zwar folgendes
wir haben auch oftmals einschreiten mit
combo die leute gesagt haben sie haben
ihr öl abgewogen und sie haben ein
halber liter gekauft und da war kein
halbes kilogramm drin es liegt daran
dass fett oder öl eine geringere dichte
hat als wasser das heißt ein halber
liter öl ist nicht automatisch und ein
halbes kilogramm ganz ganz wichtig ein
halber liter öl ist ungefähr 4 156 gramm
genau und da müsse darauf achten das ist
kein beschluss ist es einfach so weil öl
ist einfach leichter als wasser deswegen
ist es auch so dass so ein bisschen
dickere menschen ich wir schwimmen auf
dem öl weil wir auf dem wasser weil wir
mehr in uns haben ich hab da was
verwechselt kauf ich aber auf jeden fall
liegt ein halber liter öl nicht ein
halbes kilogramm habt ihr das verstanden
das war ich hab' ich habe es auch nicht
verstanden aber egal jetzt ist so
ungefähr was ich meine
ich habe dir zugehört und hat selber
habe ich auch drüber gemacht ja und dann
gibt es ja mein gott es gibt es noch
nicht man muss doch hier aufpassen wenn
wir das machen es ist echt will ich eine
ganz krasse arbeit da muss man den kopf
dabei seien deswegen tut mir nicht von
der arbeit an denken
ich habe im kopf bei ihm und habe
überlegt ob das mit der dichte ob er das
richtig gesagt hat und
456 wird sagen tor
wahnsinniger ich würde sagen wir sind
ein richtiger anfänger ist so echt
wirklich froh dann nochmal da muss man
echt aufpassen ich muss sagen ich guck
mal wie schnell ich bin und kümmere mich
schnell meine frau ist
merkmal das
band
perfekt im real life steht ist eine viel
schneller aus ja das war jetzt nur als
logo
ok 40 tonner beladen ich hoffe es müsste
mal reichen jetzt geht's nach
deutschland von dort aus nach österreich
in die schweiz überall in die welt aus
waghäusel ach das erhöht nicht ganz
große geschichte dieses jahr und jetzt
geht's ab rät er es schafft hier also
fix und fertig jetzt
okay
ja muss mich schon stolz
wahnsinn